Congratulations, you've made it through
the first hurdle in iOS development.
You have UI elements, and
you've wired them up to call
your code with IB actions.
And you've reach back to
the UI using IB outlets.
In the second part of this lesson,
you're going to learn how to set up
multiple views, so that you can go
between two different view controllers.
No more single view applications for
you.
Most iOS applications you will
be developing will venture
further than a single screen.
In order to use multiple
view controllers,
you will need another class,
that let's you navigate between them.
There are two common classes to use for
handling multiple view
controllers in iOS.
UI navigation controller and,
UI tab are controller.
Both of these are covered in depth
when you get to UI kit fundamentals
in the next module.
For now let's just discuss the basics of
a UINavigation Navigation controller.
The UINavigation Controller is
a class that handles a stack
of multiple view controllers.
Like any other stack in computer science
or real life, you can insert and
remove items from the stack.
In the UINavigation Controller you start
out with a single view controller,
called the rootViewController.
You can add as many of your controllers
on top of it as you'd like.
In pitch perfect we're going to
have just two view controllers.
One for recording, and one for playback.
So our use UINavigationController,
will be just for those two screens.
Before we can run, we need to walk.
Currently our app have the view
controller named ViewController
as a start of the app.
With the main story
board opened selected.
Notice the little gray arrow
here that indicates that
this is the initial view controller.
If you have multiple view controllers,
you can drag this arrow to change
which view controller to storyboard, and
therefore your app, will start with.
This arrow is also
driven by the checkbox
titled is initial view controller
here in the attribute inspector.
If you uncheck this arrow,
the storyboard won't know
what view controller to start the app
with and you'll get a runtime crash.
Make sure the is initial
view controller is checked.
With the view controller selected,
the orange circle here in the document
outline, go into the editor menu and
select embed in navigation controller.
You can see that x code has
created a UInavigation controller
to start the app, and that our view
controller is the root view controller
of that navigation controller.
Now you're ready to add more view
controllers to pitch perfect.